ladies
ladies
listen up this is for you
we need to have a talk
okay
let's play the video this is from tiktok
as well
endless miserable cycle it's called a
woman explains the exasperating state of
dating today
true can be exasperating we need to
watch this i'm gonna let you watch it in
full it's not that long and then we're
gonna talk ladies pay attention okay
let's go every time i see a woman i want
to talk to my first thought is do they
really want to be approached i feel like
what's so hard about dating in our
modern world is that all the nice like
respectable men don't want to bother us
and so they never talk to us in person
and all the jerks don't give a [ __ ] and
they're the ones who approach us so then
we're like stop approaching us and all
the nice guys are like okay we won't and
it's just an endless miserable cycle
every time okay so i love that she made
this video i do i give her props for
putting it out there this is her opinion
ladies i'm talking to you first of all i
know tyler's eager to hear what i'm
going to say about this one the nice
respectable guys are tired of getting
burned
that's why they don't come up to you
because they're tired they show up at
the bar on a saturday
maybe they're not the most adept at
flirting okay but maybe they don't have
game
okay maybe they come up to you they're a
little shy
they're a little unsure
they really want to get to know you
they put an effort they pay for your
drink
they take that first step they're like
i'm here for the right reasons and you
know what you get bored and you're like
i don't know he's kind of like
and you wind up paying all your
attention to the douche at the end of
the bar who didn't buy your drink in
fact that guy walked up took the drink
that the nice guy bought you and just
slid that in as if he bought it
right and you decided not not the girl
who made this video i'm speaking
generally you decided to maybe you go
home with that guy at the end of the
night he seems like fine he's not oh
he's like a bad boy i don't know
does he have a bike oh
so you have a helmet for me
you're in that head
so now that nice guy gets the message
well i'm just not gonna do this because
it doesn't pay the bad boys are getting
rewarded ladies you own the cycle
it's you
don't put it on the guys
don't make this about the guy this isn't
about the guys this is about you
you need to start paying attention to
the good guys they'll come up to you
more you need to stop rewarding the bad
boys
you need to teach them
so here's some advice
don't put the goods out there unless
someone earns it
by earn it i mean they have to be
invested in you they have to take you
out on dates they have to call you
they have to prioritize you
they have to make you feel good maybe
they open the car door for you imagine
that something right out of 1985.
maybe they pay for your dinner
maybe they call you make sure oh hey how
did it go yeah i had a really good time
pick up the phone not a text
not
2022 gentlemanly
they treat you with respect you feel
good about that situation all that needs
to happen before you put the goods out
there
you're then teaching that man
that your body is your temple
you put the goods out there for a bad
boy on night one because you're bored
you also taught that guy that he doesn't
have to be a good guy he can be a douche
and he still wins at the end of the day
the cycle happens because of you
put it on the guys and i'm not saying
guys don't have a responsibility you
should want to be a good dude
right
but not everybody's going to be like
that what i'm trying to say is ladies
you're not powerless in this game
you need to take ownership of your role
in this
and ladies saying oh i tell the jerks to
leave me alone do you
listen if you do
more power to you i hate bad boys i
never gave them the time of day i gave
one guy the time of day for a little
while who wound up being a bad boy and
the second i found out he was a bad boy
his [ __ ] was outside
i'm not lying it doesn't interest me bad
boys are like fun for like five minutes
if that
and i'm gonna be blunt they're usually
not even good in bed
just gonna say they're used to taking
care of themselves and not you it's a
pattern that goes deep
you all know it ladies listening
invest your time in people who are
investing their time in you and that
will creep out
you can't teach your daughters that
lesson unless you do it yourself
okay so it starts with you so i'm not
saying there aren't bad guys out there
i'm not saying that you there aren't
guys that are going to do you wrong no
matter what they exist your job is to
tell those guys take a walk when that
happens
your job is to pay attention to the guys
who really want to do right by you
your job is to send a message to the
douche at the end of the bar who doesn't
want to buy you the drink because he
doesn't want to spend the money that
that's not going to work for you you're
not going to go home with him you're not
going to give him the time of day and
instead you're going to go back to that
conversation with the guy who wasn't so
great at flirting but would probably
make a great boyfriend
so that's what i'm closing with today
because it's important this dating stuff
is really really important
and i think that it affects how you feel
about yourself
it affects how you carry yourself in the
world and it's also part of turning like
girls into women
we also talk about you know oftentimes
boys into men well girls into women too
you've got to stand up for yourself
that's how you stand up for yourself
so i hear her
but i'd be curious i don't know her life
i don't know what she's doing maybe
she's doing everything right
but if not
always be willing to make those tweaks
the bad boys are never going to be worth
it until they change i'm not saying they
can't change
but they're going to change because you
don't tolerate their [ __ ] or they're not
going to change at all but if there's a
chance it's going to be because of you
ladies you have a lot of power tyler
knows
you have a lot of power is all i'm
saying if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]